bonjour et bienvenue pour ce top 5 des
plus incroyables fossiles jamais
découvert découvrira fossiles c'est déjà
un petit miracle en soi puisqu'il est
généralement convenu qu'à peine un seul
individu sur 10000 d'une espèce donnée
connaîtra la fossilisation évidemment ce
chiffre dépendra d énormément de
paramètres
par exemple vous aurez plus de chance de
vous fossilisés si vous avez des organes
dur comme une coquille ou des eaux
et si vous cassez votre pipe dans l'eau
donc pour faire carrière en
paléontologie c'est très facile il
suffit de se jeter à l'eau et les
téléfilms comme du gros sel celle là
quoi qu'il en soit vos probabilités de
léguer votre corps fossilisés à la
postérité sont infimes
ce qui fait de chaque découverte de
fossiles un événement particulièrement
émouvant la fossilisation est donc un
événement rare et précieux et étant
donnée la dérisoire probabilité que cela
arrive à ne serait-ce qu'un seul de vos
il ya certaines choses qu'on ne s'attend
pas à voir se fossiliser et on voit si
un petit aperçu des quotas la dhr aux
normes unifiées de la crypte delaunay
ère aux états unis il s'agit d'un
fossile exceptionnels découverts par un
lycéen d'à peine 16 ans passionné de
dinosaures et ben y en a un autre qui
s'appelle leonardo et qui aussi
l'exceptionnelle laisse mourir
ce n'est qu'une vieille carcasse tout
décès chez sas est un fossile
exceptionnel une grenouille parfaitement
préservée tout en phosphates et c'est du
made in france madame découverte en 1873
dans la région du quercy la région du
quercy dans le centre de la france a
fourni des millions de fausses il
documente en plus de 30 millions
d'années d'évolution et que les
chercheurs du monde entier sont venus
étudier
c'est un gisement que le monde entier
nous envie d'ordinaire les fossiles de
grenouilles sont extrêmement rares car
leurs eaux sont délicats et leur peau ne
comporte pas de solides s'écaille comme
celle de notre ado rosoor du tout à
l'heure notre grenouille est
exceptionnelle à plus d'un titre
elle n'a pas seulement conservé les
détails de sa peau avec une exquise
finesse elle a aussi conservé ses eaux
et oui une analyse scanner faite par des
chercheurs de poitiers en 2013 a montré
qu'elle n'était pas qu'une simple
empreinte mais un spécimen
complet parfaitement préservée squelette
en place ce qui a permis d'établir
qu'elle appartenait à l'espèce thomass
taurus gti connu uniquement jusqu'à lors
par des fragments osseux
chapeau l'artiste 4 d'ordinaire ce qu'on
appelle le cerveau fossile n'est pas
réellement de cerveau mais le moulage
artificiel ou naturel de la qualité qui
contient le cerveau et ce dernier ne
reflète pas forcément bien la
morphologie du vrae cerveau voire même
pas du tout comme c'est le cas chez les
poissons ou encore chez les baleines
il peut arriver parfois que l'on
découvre le cerveau frais d'une espèce
éteinte comme celui de ce petit mammouth
nommé yucca dont on a retrouvé le
cerveau encore entier dans la boîte
crânienne parfaitement préservée de la
décomposition par le froid de sacy berry
natal et ce depuis plus de dix mille ans
ce n'est ni plus ni moins que le seul
cerveau d'espèces éteintes jamais
documentées mais ce cerveau n'est pas
vraiment un fossile c'est toujours un
cerveau est en fait l'utilisation du
terme cerveau fossile était un abus de
langage jusqu'à la découverte de ceux ci
un véritable cerveau fossile de cachalot
provenant de californie et datant d'une
dizaine de millions d'années on sait
encore que peu de choses sur ce fossile
car il est encore en cours d'étude
depuis 2008 à l'université de los
angeles la fin me dit cerveau de ces
spécimens semble s'être comme
cristallisé comme dans un module est le
mieux c'est qu'il y en aurait un autre
découvert bien des années plus tôt et
appartenant cette fois à une baleine à
fanons qui a dit qu'il ne restait plus
rien à découvrir en matière de fossiles
et 0,3 comme nous l'avons dit tout à
l'heure la fossilisation est déjà un
petit miracle en soi et la préservation
d'un spécimen complet avec des tissus
mous est encore plus rare par exemple
celui que vous voyez en ce moment nous
vient d'allemagne
c'est le seul et unique primate fossile
dont on possède un squelette complet il
répond au doux sobriquet de ida mais
pour l'occasion les scientifiques l'ont
13 officiellement et très modestement
baptisée darwinius passe assez darwin
qui perd la boule sa découverte et la
description en 2009 ont engrangé un
enthousiasme sans pareil pourtant
quelques années plus tôt paraissait plus
discrètement la description d'un fossile
oh oh combien plus rares et plus
exceptionnelle encore que celui de ida
et qui fait l'objet de ce numéro 3 en
2006 une équipe franco chinoise dirigée
par le paléontologue français eric
buffetaut dévoile l'existence de ce
fossile
voilà qui me voici le fossile on ne peut
plus authentique d'un embryon de
reptiles à deux têtes daté du jurassique
à deux têtes
rendez vous compte les reptiles à deux
têtes sont des mutants extrêmement rare
de nos jours et la probabilité que l'un
d'entre eux fossilisés infiniment faible
et ajoutez ensuite à cela la probabilité
qu un paléontologue le retrouve et vous
aurez compris pourquoi la photo de ce
petit monstre devrait figurer en face de
la définition du mot exceptionnelle dans
le dictionnaire un fossile ce n'est pas
qu'un simple objet biologique resté
préservé dans la roche non non non en
fait dans un fossile la roche va
littéralement remplacer la structure
moléculaire interne de l'os tout en en
préservant finement la forme extérieure
la nature d'associer sa couleur
notamment dépendra donc de la roche qui
le contient si la roche qui entoura
noces ou un coquillage quand il se
fossilise est du charbon par exemple
alors le fossile aura toutes les chances
d'être non plus fait de calcium mais de
charbon et dans certaines conditions
chimiques très complexe impliquant des
sources hydrothermales à plus de 300
degrés est saturé en silice et en sels
minéraux
les fossiles seront en émeraude
il n'existe qu'une poignée de ces
fossiles en pierres précieuses provenant
tous d'une mine d'émeraudes situé en
colombie et qui sera ta ta ta ta ta ta
là dans les commentaires on est en train
de nous écrire que trois pauvres
escargots même en émeraudes ça fait pas
la deuxième marche du podium
ah ouais alors comme ça vous fout du
cours du louvre il nous faut du baisse
alors que diriez vous d'un squelette
entier de reptiles marins géants de
l'ère des dinosaures et ce tout au
minéral semi précieux voici pour vos
yeux ébahis et eric le pliosaure
découvert en australie et dont le
squelette quasi complet s'est
entièrement est naturellement
transformer en opale son ami vient de la
chanson des monty python éric the ralph
biggs
pour la petite histoire eric a été
découvert par un mineur australien et
fut acquis lors d'une vente aux enchères
par l'australian muséum pour la coquette
somme de 4 123 mille dollars
maintenant baptisé et menez auris y
trônent majestueusement à l'australian
newseum bien protégé des convoitises
numéro un
mais qu'est-ce qui peut battre le
squelette en pierres précieuses d'un
géant des mers préhistorique à mais pour
ça il suffit de se rendre compte que
tous les fossiles que nous avons vu
jusqu'ici sont des restes d'animaux
morts
oui oui des fossiles d'animaux morts oui
jusque là tout va bien je crois vous je
repousse situer le problème est
justement le numéro un doit être un
fossile laissé par un animal vivant car
qu'il s'agisse d'une dent d'un squelette
entier ou même d'une momie fossiles
tous sont des restes d'animaux morts
alors que les empreintes de pas par
exemple ne sont pas des reste préservé
d'un cadavre mais bel et bien la trace
de l'activité d'un être vivant fait de
son vivant
voici par exemple une empreinte
provenant de la piste de l'italie en
tanzanie
les empreintes de cette piste date de
3,6 millions d'années et sont d'autant
plus exceptionnel qu'elles ont été
faites par deux seuls bipèdes comme en
témoigne ici la présence d'un pouce
opposable sur le pied on ne sait pas
exactement de quelle espèce il s'agit
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ces deux
sages marcher sur leurs pattes de
derrière
ce sont des singes qui marchent debout
des hommes en somme tels qu'ils étaient
il ya trois millions d'années à l'uci
peut bien aller se rhabiller car ces
empreintes fraîchement imprimés dans la
volcaniques sont certainement le
témoignage le plus direct de la bipédie
de tous les premiers hominidés loin
devant les simples hypothèses que l'on
peut faire à partir de l'interprétation
de quelques fragments de squelettes donc
non les empreintes de pas ne sont pas
des faux cils secondaire ou
inintéressant mais au contraire elle
documente directement non pas la mort
mais la vie des êtres qui les en fait
alors qu'elle emprunte ce sera la
première de notre classement mon
attention et notre grande gagnante est
cette empreinte cette toute petite
enfance ne pas de rien du tout oui mais
qui n'a qu'une seule particularité et
pas des moindres elle est située sur
notre astre de la nuit j'ai nommé la
lune
eric les traces laissées par les
différents astronautes qui sont allés
sur la lune sont celles de formes
vivantes nous et dans la mesure où en
l'absence d'atmosphère il n'ya pas
d'érosion sur la lune on peut considérer
qu'elle y seront à jamais imprimé dans
la poussière lunaire
tels des fossiles d'ailleurs l'érosion
sur terre les tempêtes la pluie le vent
et les mouvements de la croûte terrestre
auront sûrement raison de nos restes et
or ont fait disparaître toutes traces de
notre existence sur notre planète avant
que celle des astronautes ne disparaisse
de la lune ainsi c'est très ironiquement
sur la dune que perdureront certainement
les derniers témoignages fossiles du
passage de notre espèce sur terre ce
stade-ci ainsi terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi pour en savoir plus vous pouvez
consulter les liens qui sont dans la
description ainsi que notre page
facebook où vous retrouverez la
description et l'histoire de chacun des
fossiles présentés ici ainsi que
l'actualité scientifique tous les jours
merci à tous
il aurait bien fait un petit numéro zéro
tu vois un truc genre pour les fossiles
qu'on n'a pas encore découvert un truc
encore plus loin que la lune encore plus
loin que les étoiles les fossiles sur
mars
t'imagines les gros titres des journaux
la paléontologie interstellaire les
fossiles par delà les étoiles ouais
enfin pour l'instant
tu peux garder les pieds sur terre il ya
bien assez de boulot à faire ici à ça du
boulot pour les paléontologues on en a
c'est sûr un mais le problème c'est
qu'on ne donne pas de travail alors